Ben Affleck's Batman will live on in the multiverse-twisting
"Flash" movie – but Matt Reeves' "The Batman"
is doing something new in a world all its
own.
Here's everything you need to know about Robert
Pattinson and "The Batman."
"The Batman" has been in development for so
long that the Bat was originally supposed
to be a totally different man.
Originally, "The Batman" was imagined as an
entry in the DC Extended Universe, working
in the same world as "Man of Steel" and "Batman
v. Superman: Dawn of Justice"
At the time, it was a given that Ben Affleck
would be reprising the role of Bruce Wayne,
while also serving as the movie's writer and
director.
Once Affleck stepped down as director and
his script was shelved, new director Matt
Reeves came on board with his own pitch for
a Batman film that would call for a younger
actor in the role.
Robert Pattinson was Reeves' first choice
for Bruce Wayne, with the filmmaker saying
he wrote the part specifically for him.
Pattinson is best known to the public for
his lead role in the "Twilight" films, but
in the years since those movies came and went,
he's also become a critical darling for his
work in smaller films like "Good Time" and
"The Lighthouse."
Pattinson's casting was something of a surprise.
For years, he's avoided major franchise projects,
reportedly having a less-than-stellar experience
with "Twilight."
But it turns out that he, like a lot of people,
is a lifelong Batman fan, and jumped at the
chance to portray his own version of the character.
Pattinson's casting in 2019 was met with a
predictable amount of fan backlash, and Pattinson
also stirred up a bit of controversy when
he jokingly claimed he wouldn't be hitting
the gym to beef up for the role.
This kind of criticism is nothing new, and
it's hard to take too seriously; remember
that originally people had doubts about Heath
Ledger as the Joker.
Other criticisms around his interpretation
haven't made a lot of sense, like mocking
the so-called "emo" black makeup around Pattinson's
eyes when he removes his cowl.
Those critics are apparently unaware that
every live-action Batman since Michael Keaton
has filled in the space between their eyes
and their cowl with black make-up … at least
when the cowl is on.
Unlike the Caped Crusader in "Batman Returns"
and "Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice,"
this Batman still has the make-up on when
he removes his cowl, which just makes sense.
One thing's for certain: Pattinson's take
will certainly be different from what we've
seen on screen before – less charming, more
broken.
The actor told MovieMaker,
"I want to play a dirty, dirty, slimy Batman."
Soon after Ben Affleck walked away from the
"Batman" directing gig, news broke that Matt
Reeves would be taking on the task of shepherding
"The Batman" from concept to completion.
While "The Batman" will be Reeves' first foray
into the world of superheroes, he is no stranger
to films featuring high concepts and larger-than-life
characters, as evidenced by his directorial
work on "Cloverfield" and the rebooted "Planet
of the Apes" films.
At first, the intent was for Reeves to use
Ben Affleck's script, directing Affleck in
the role.
But a few months after he was brought on board
as director, Reeves announced that he was
tossing out Affleck's screenplay and starting
from scratch.
While Reeves' script features a younger protagonist
than Affleck's would have, the director told
Variety that he still hopes to deliver a mature,
ambitious film that doesn't talk down to its
audience and offers a quote, "epic and emotional
new take" on the character.
When "The Batman" was first announced, it
was intended as another chapter in the DC
Extended Universe, pitting Ben Affleck's veteran
Dark Knight against the assassin Slade Wilson,
a.k.a.
Deathstroke, to be played by Joe Manganiello.
Manganiello's role in the film was teased
in Zack Snyder's version of "Justice League,"
which showed Lex Luthor revealing Batman's
secret identity to Deathstroke.
"His name is Bruce Wayne."
According to Manganiello, Deathstroke would
have used this information to exact his cruel
vengeance on those close to Bruce Wayne, and
to do battle with both Batman and his teammate
Batgirl.
This one of the many plot threads from "Zack
Snyder's Justice League" that are now left
dangling indefinitely as DC Films retools
its cinematic universe.
After discarding the original script for "The
Batman," Matt Reeves set out to write a new
story that would stand more on its own.
He said in a 2022 interview with Esquire,
"I respect that the DC Universe has become
an extended universe and all the movies were
kind of connected.
But another 'Batman' film, it shouldn’t
have to carry the weight of connecting the
characters from all those other movies.
I didn’t want them in there."
Instead, "The Batman" would be set in its
own continuity, divorced from the DCEU.
But fans itching for more for more Batfleck
will still get at least one final film featuring
his take on the character, when "The Flash"
hits theaters in November 2022.
In an interview with the Hollywood Reporter
in 2019, Reeves said that his screenplay for
"The Batman" would be a, quote, "point of
view-driven, noir Batman tale."
He also said it would lean into the notion
of Bruce Wayne as the world's greatest detective.
Reeves also promised an emotional, transformative
arc for the character.
Reeves told Digital Spy that he sees Batman
as a, quote, "tortured soul who is struggling
to find a way to do the right thing in a very
imperfect world."
As Christian Bale's Batman famously said in
"Batman Begins,"
"It's not who I am underneath, but what I
do that defines me."
Based on Reeves' comments, we expect his take
on the character to be more introspective
and intellectual than what we've seen in previous
films.
While it's probably a safe bet that "The Batman"
will feature its fair share of fistfights,
explosions, and mind-blowing Bat-gadgets — after
all, this is still a DC superhero movie — don't
be surprised if Reeves' Batman turns out to
be defined by who he is underneath after all.
It was revealed early on that key villain
roles in "The Batman" would be filled by the
Penguin and Catwoman.
After several rounds of lively casting rumors
that included Vanessa Hudgens, Aubrey Plaza,
Lupita Nyong'o, Tessa Thompson, Gugu Mbatha-Raw,
Alexandra Shipp, and Logan Browning, speculation
about who will be portraying Selina Kyle in
"The Batman" finally came to an end.
"Big Little Lies" star Zoë Kravitz will be
portraying the Caped Crusader's iconic femme
fatale in Matt Reeves' film.
Selina has a rich and complex history with
Bruce Wayne in the comics, and her role in
the film could go any number of directions.
"The Batman" won't be Kravitz's first or even
second foray into comic book fare, although
it'll be her first starring role in a superhero
film.
She previously played the mutant Angel Salvadore,
a.k.a.
Tempest, in 2011's "X-Men: First Class," and
also provided the voice for Mary Jane in 2018's
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse."
The most purr-fectly relevant gig on her resume?
She's already played Catwoman once before,
having lent her voice to "The LEGO Batman
Movie."
While Catwoman has rarely been depicted as
an outright villain in Batman mythology, the
past 30 years in particular have seen her
rise into an anti-hero in her own right.
In the comics, Selina Kyle has led her own
ongoing comics series almost continuously
since 1993, after a limited series run in
1989.
She's arguably the protagonist of 1992's "Batman
Returns," got a much-mocked film of her own
in 2004, and fought alongside Batman in 2012's
"The Dark Knight Rises."
If the trailers are any indication, "The Batman"
will explore the character from a few different
angles — as a thief, as a vigilante, and
as a romantic foil for Batman.
Zoë Kravitz told Empire magazine that "The
Batman" is "an origin story for Selina."
In keeping with Matt Reeves' vision of "The
Batman" as a film noir, Kravitz sees Selina
as a femme fatale, as well as a fighter.
Kravitz studied a mix of different martial
arts that would be practical for a smaller,
leaner person to use when taking on larger
opponents.
Selina's severe haircut and makeshift Catwoman
disguise seen in the film seem heavily inspired
by her appearance in the famous four-issue
arc "Batman: Year One," by writer Frank Miller
and artist David Mazzucchelli.
In this story, Selina follows Batman's example
and creates a costumed identity under which
to stalk the roofs of Gotham, but she and
Batman don't have much interaction.
The early flirtation between Bat and Cat is
explored more fully in its spiritual sequel,
"The Long Halloween" by Jeph Loeb and Tim
Sale, which has been cited along with "Year
One" as one of the inspirations for "The Batman."
The path "The Batman" took from announcement
to release spanned nearly eight years.
It was among the slate of 10 DC Comics-inspired
films that Warner Bros. announced way back
in October 2014, before cameras had even stopped
rolling on "Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice."
The Matt Reeves "Batman" was initially supposed
to be released on June 25, 2021, but this
announcement was made before the start of
the COVID-19 pandemic, which halted production
about a quarter of the way through shooting.
This pushed the release to October 1, 2021,
but an outbreak of the virus on set in September
2020 paused production for an additional two
weeks.
This may have contributed to the release date
being moved yet again, though it's more likely
that Warner Bros. simply wanted a few more
months for cases of the disease to decline
… and, perhaps, to not have to release the
film day-and-date on HBO Max with the rest
of their 2021 slate.
Shortly after the second COVID delay, "The
Batman" received its third and final release
date of March 4, 2022.
The film will play exclusively in theaters
for 45 days, and then stream on HBO Max beginning
April 19.
"The Batman" finds Bruce Wayne in less than
ideal condition, and we're not just talking
about those scars on his back.
A year into his crimefighting career as Batman,
Wayne is still struggling with some deep psychological
scars and allowing his life outside the cape
and cowl to crumble.
Writer-director Matt Reeves has stated in
an interview with Empire that this version
of Bruce Wayne is "not really a socialite
at all" and is letting his family home and
legacy decay.
Reeves' inspiration for the depressed, rage-fueled
Bruce Wayne?
Tragic '90s rock icon Kurt Cobain.
According to his feature in Esquire, Reeves
became fixated on the Nirvana song "Something
in the Way" while writing the first act of
the script, leading him to imagine Bruce Wayne
as a total recluse struggling with addiction
— in his case, to violence.
He cites the song, which was remixed for film's
first theatrical trailer, and the Gus Van
Sant film "Last Days," which centered around
a Kurt Cobain-type character, as inspiring
this take on Bruce.
According to Pattinson, his Batman is constantly
battling against his own urge to kill, displacing
the rage he feels towards his parents' killer
onto the other criminals of Gotham.
Being Batman is an outlet for his anger, but
not necessarily a salve.
In short, he's not getting better.
Early in the development of "The Batman,"
Matt Reeves parried speculation that his "young
Batman" movie would be yet another origin
story.
Instead, Reeves has defined his film as a
"Year Two" Batman tale, skipping past the
well-trod territory of "Batman Begins" and
"Batman: Year One."
Reeves told Esquire,
"A lot of times you see stories where he's
already become Batman, then the Rogues' Gallery
villain comes in, and it's then their story,
and you watch him go toe-to-toe with them.
I wanted the main character in the story to
be a Batman who was a year in and still trying
to figure out how to do this, how to be effective,
and he's not necessarily succeeding."
Any time a filmmaker comes on board to "reboot"
the Batman character for the silver screen,
you'll hear the same familiar refrain — they
want to take the character back to his gritty,
pulpy roots.
Usually, this means looking back at one of
two essential graphic novels of the mid-1980s,
"The Dark Knight Returns" and "Batman: Year
One," both written by Frank Miller, which
helped codify a more grounded take that had
been evolving for decades in the pages of
the monthly comics.
Matt Reeves is certainly not an exception
to this — "Year One" is indeed one of his
favorites.
He's also cited Jeph Loeb and Tim Sale's 1997
mini-series "The Long Halloween" as an inspiration.
In fact, at one point Warner Bros. Animation
was told to put their own adaptation of the
"Long Halloween" story on hold because it
was being considered as the direct source
material for "The Batman."
It wouldn't be the first time the comic served
as inspiration for a Batman film, either;
"The Long Halloween" is one of the clearest
comics influences on 2008's "The Dark Knight."
More exciting, however, is Reeves' professed
love of not only pre-Miller Batman creators
like Bill Finger and Neal Adams, but the 2000
graphic novel "Batman: Ego" by cartoonist
Darwyn Cooke.
"Ego" is a deep and visually stunning psychological
study of the Dark Knight, perfect inspiration
for a Batman film that's intended to be richly
emotional and focused on the title character.
The trailers also hint that certain aspects
of Scott Snyder and Greg Capullo's run on
the character may make an appearance as well.
Character actor Jeffrey Wright becomes the
fifth man to portray Gotham City Police Commissioner
James Gordon in a live-action feature, following
Neil Hamilton in the 1966 continuation of
the Batman television series, Pat Hingle in
the Burton and Schumacher series, Gary Oldman
in the "Dark Knight" trilogy, and J.K.
Simmons in the DC Extended Universe.
Wright is no stranger to major franchises,
having played CIA Agent Felix Leiter in three
installments of the James Bond series, Beetee
in "The Hunger Games: Mockingjay," and having
lent his voice to Uatu the Watcher in "Marvel's
What If?"
In the years since his casting in "The Batman,"
Jeffrey Wright has also lent his voice to
the Dark Knight himself in "Batman: The Audio
Adventures," a campy radio-style drama that
streams on HBO Max.
According to an interview with IndieWire,
Wright was attracted to the realistic tone
of the film.
"I saw the themes around corruption and class
tensions and all of the things that he wanted
to bring from the outside into this world
so it had some relevance."
Warner Bros. confirmed in October 2019 that
Paul Dano had officially come aboard the film
as the Riddler.
Dano is well suited for a dark and menacing
villain, having been nominated for an Emmy
for his work on the Showtime limited series
"Escape at Dannemora," in which he portrayed
real-life convicted murderer David Sweat.
Dano has played a wide variety of roles during
his eclectic career, from gently comedic turns
in films like "Swiss Army Man" and "Little
Miss Sunshine," to more serious roles in films
such as "Prisoners," "Okja," and "There Will
Be Blood."
The thread that seems to tie all of Dano's
characters together is a sense of deep interior
personality and emotional complexity, which
will serve him well as the enigmatic Riddler.
Matt Reeves' casting of the soulful, often
somber Dano is a far cry from the rubber-limbed
Jim Carrey, who played the role in 1995's
"Batman Forever."
"Post-homicidal depression."
When Matt Reeves imagined his ideal Batman
film, it was always through the lens of a
detective story.
From there, it was a logical leap for the
film's main antagonist to be more of an intellectual
challenge for Batman than a physical threat.
Hence, the Riddler, a Batman villain famous
for his puzzles and mind games rather than
fighting prowess.
In "The Batman," Matt Reeves has reimagined
the Riddler as a serial killer in the tradition
of the Zodiac Killer, the real-life murderer
who mailed clues about his targets and identity
to newspapers in the late 1960s.
Reeves told Esquire,
"I started thinking of the Zodiac Killer,
because he did create a costume for himself
and he wore a black hood, he had his own insignia.
He was an early anti-superhero, a scary figure
who terrorized California."
This version of the Riddler, who uses his
canonical birth name from the comics, Edward
Nashton, taunts Batman with written and recorded
messages, and may even already be aware of
his secret identity as Bruce Wayne.
Indeed, Riddler seems to be directing Batman
toward solving a mystery about corruption
in Gotham that involves the Wayne family.
Without question the most surprising casting
choice in "The Batman" is Colin Farrell as
Oswald "Penguin" Cobblepot.
Cobblepot is typically portrayed as a short,
ugly man with a rotund body, a far cry from
Colin Farrell's leading-man good looks.
But, like Danny Devito, and, to a lesser extent,
"Gotham" actor Robin Lord Taylor, before him,
Farrell's appearance has been altered via
applied prosthetics to make him a closer match
for the notorious crime boss of the comics.
It took between two and four hours to apply
Farrell's facial scars, a heftier neck, and
receding hairline, though his transformation
doesn't stop there.
Farrell is practically unrecognizable in his
performance, donning the type of thick New
York accent you'd hear in a Scorsese gangster
film.
"Woah, take it easy sweetheart."
Or should we say Coppola — Farrell cites
"The Godfather" character Fredo Corleone,
the weak-willed older brother of kingpin Michael
Corleone, as his inspiration for the character.
Like Fredo, Farrell told Empire Online that
his "Oz" Cobblepot is, quote "crippled by
the insignificance that he lives within, in
a family that is full of very strong, very
bright, very capable, very violent men."
It's a role he says he'd be interested in
exploring in a sequel, and he may very well
get the chance to spend more time with the
character — there's a spinoff series for
the Penguin in early development at HBO Max.
In the comics, Oswald comes from old Gotham
money, operating his criminal empire under
the very thin guise of legitimate business.
He's often portrayed as one of the only "traditional"
gangsters to maintain his foothold in the
Gotham underworld after the rise of more outlandish
villains like the Joker, Two-Face, and Black
Mask.
Whether Oz's inferiority complex may come
from feeling overshadowed by his family legacy,
or from the changing face of crime in Gotham
in "The Batman," we'll just have to wait and
see.
The impressive cast of "The Batman" also includes
Emmy-winning character actor John Turturro,
who will be playing Gotham's powerful crime
boss Carmine Falcone.
Sometimes nicknamed "The Roman" and based
on Marlon Brando's character from "The Godfather,"
Falcone first debuted in Frank Miller and
David Mazzucchelli's"Batman: Year One" comics,
but assumed a much more prominent role later
on in "Batman: The Long Halloween."
In the comics, Falcone effectively runs Gotham
City and is determined to put a stop to Batman's
vigilante actions in order to solidify his
stranglehold on the city.
Falcone has previously been portrayed onscreen
by Tom Wilkinson in the film "Batman Begins"
and John Doman on the television series "Gotham."
Further complicating Falcone's relationship
with Batman in the comics is the fact that
Bruce's father, Thomas Wayne, once saved Falcone's
life, a life debt which Falcone has sworn
to someday repay.
Andy Serkis, the actor best known for his
groundbreaking CGI "performance capture" roles
as Gollum in "The Lord of the Rings" and Caesar
in the rebooted "Planet of the Apes" trilogy,
will show his actual face in "The Batman"
as Alfred Pennyworth, the Wayne family butler
who raised the young Bruce after the murder
of his parents.
Serkis becomes the fifth actor to play Alfred
in a live-action feature film, following Alan
Napier, Michael Gough, Michael Caine, and
Jeremy Irons.
The character has also been a fixture on the
small screen in recent years, portrayed by
Sean Pertwee on "Gotham" from 2014 to 2019
and the lead character of his own series,
"Pennyworth," starring Jack Bannon, on HBO
Max.
Serkis has plenty of history with Matt Reeves,
who also directed "Dawn of the Planet of the
Apes" and "War for the Planet of the Apes,"
and Reeves has apparently secured Serkis a
sizable role in "The Batman."
Serkis has told interviewers that the emotional
connection between Alfred and Bruce is "the
center" of the film, and trailers have hinted
that the story may hinge on some Wayne family
secret from which Alfred has been trying to
protect his surrogate son.
A larger role for Alfred in this film would
be in keeping with the way his character has
been expanded in the comics over the past
few decades, from a relatively passive participant
in Batman's war on crime to an irreplaceable
asset with a history as a military medic and
a secret agent of the British government.
Particularly during Batman's early years before
the expansion of the Bat-family, Alfred is
Bruce's only friend and confidante.
Similarly to the way Matt Reeves announced
the casting for Andy Serkis as Alfred, the
director took to Twitter again at the beginning
of December 2019 to reveal that Peter Sarsgaard
had joined the cast of "The Batman."
Unlike Reeves' previous few casting announcements,
he didn't hashtag this tweet with the name
of the character Sarsgaard will be playing,
instead just sharing an animated gif.
Sources originally told The Hollywood Reporter
that the actor would either be playing a corrupt
cop named Wasserman or a district attorney,
leading to speculation that he could be playing
Harvey Dent — better known as the iconic
Batman villain Two-Face.
However, in early 2020, a Warner Bros. official
press release identified Sarsgaard's character
as "Gotham D.A.
Gil Colson," a new character who doesn't exist
in the comics.
The character has already made an appearance
in a promo clip, being used as a hostage by
the Riddler during a brazen attack on a funeral.
"Christ, it's Colson."
On February 13, 2020, Matt Reeves gave us
all an early Valentine's Day gift in the form
of a red-tinted first look at Robert Pattinson
as the caped crusader.
The 55-second camera test features Pattinson
in the full Batsuit and cowl, emerging from
the darkness into a sharp, crimson close-up.
Even this partial glimpse let fans know that
Pattinson's Batman would have a very different
look than the Dark Knights that have come
before.
But what really sells the look isn't any particular
alchemy of materials or cut, but Pattinson's
distinctive face, which becomes the ultimate
focus of the short video.
Like Ben Affleck and Christian Bale before
him, Pattinson is gifted with an authentic
Bruce Wayne jawline, cutting a silhouette
so recognizable that it makes you really wonder
why he thinks he can get away with only covering
up half his face.
On March 4, 2020, Matt Reeves tweeted out
the first look at the new Batmobile.
Gone is the bulky tank-like Tumbler of Christopher
Nolan's "Dark Knight" trilogy, as well as
the almost comically tricked-out stealth-bomber-meets-"Fury-Road"
version of Batman's ride that Ben Affleck
drove in "Justice League."
For "The Batman," Robert Pattinson will be
driving a reimagined Batmobile that looks
like it could've been driven straight out
of a high-end garage, as opposed to a high-tech
research facility, a la Batman Begins.
This new take on Bruce Wayne's iconic transport
leans much more toward a classic muscle car
than its more military-inspired predecessors,
calling to mind well-known models like the
1970 Dodge Challenger and the Pontiac GTO.
Since "The Batman" is supposed to take place
early on in Bruce's tenure as the Caped Crusader,
it's easy to believe that this version of
the Batmobile represents one of the billionaire
vigilante's first attempts at a superhero
car, in which he modified something he already
owned rather than building something new.
The latest version of the Batmobile comes
with a before-its-time in-dash video display,
a sleek black custom design, and an absolute
monster of an engine.
"The Batman" is deliberately isolated from
the DC Extended Universe where most of DC's
films take place, and is intended to stand
alone.
It neither relies on context from previous
film incarnations of Batman, nor does it prioritize
setting up sequels and spinoffs.
Star Robert Pattinson seemed to imply to Total
Film after seeing the finished cut that he
had a hard time imagining the movie leading
to a full film series – even though he admits
it probably will.
As he put it,
"It’s a really, really unusual Batman story,
and it almost seems harder for me to imagine
it being a series afterwards.
I mean, they always have that little bit at
the end, that’s like: ‘and coming up!’
But other than that, it feels strangely personal.
I think people will be quite shocked at how
different it is."
At the same time, it's been reported that
Warner Bros. is champing at the bit to spin
"The Batman" into a shared universe of films
and television shows, having already put two
HBO Max series into development ahead of the
film's release.
One would center around the Gotham City Police
Department, while another would focus on Colin
Farrell's Penguin.
This cross-platform Batman universe would
have to coexist alongside a few other live-action
projects set in their own continuities, but
this is nothing new.
The HBO Max series "Titans" and The CW's "Batwoman"
both feature a number of Batman characters,
take place on different Earths in the DC Multiverse.
Each show even has its own Bruce Wayne, played
by Iain Glen and Warren Christie respectively,
though both series avoid showing Batman in
costume.
And then, of course, there's the DC Extended
Universe of films, which in 2022 alone will
feature both the Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton
incarnations of Batman.
But even though Batman as a character is going
multiversal, on the big screen, it looks like
"The Batman" is set to stand alone.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.